Cela fait quelque chose d’être ici à un colloque
consacré à "Inspiré par la Nature" -- vous pouvez l’imaginer.
Et je suis ravie d’être dans la section préliminaire.
Aviez-vous remarqué que cette section est préliminaire?
Parce que ça me donne l'occasion de parler d’un de mes animaux préférés,
qui est le grèbe élégant. Vous n’avez pas vécu
tant que vous n’avez pas vu ces animaux faire leur parade nuptiale.
J’étais au lac Bowman dans le Parc national des Glaciers, au Canada,
qui est un long lac étroit avec comme des montagnes retournées dedans,
et mon ami et moi faisions de l’aviron.
Et donc nous ramions, et l’un des ces grèbes élégants passa par là.
Et ce qu’ils font pour leur parade nuptiale, c’est qu’ils se rapprochent,
tous les deux, mâle et femelle, et qu’ils commencent à courir sous l’eau.
Ils battent des pattes de plus en plus vite, jusqu’à ce qu’ils aillent si vite
qu’ils s’élèvent littéralement hors de l’eau,
et qu’ils restent dressés, en battant la surface de l’eau.
Et l’un de ces grèbes passa par là alors que nous ramions.
Nous sommes dans un deux de couple, et nous allons vraiment, vraiment vite.
Et ce grèbe, j'imagine, nous à pris pour un partenaire potentiel,
et a commencé à courir sur l’eau à côté de nous,
en une parade nuptiale -- sur des kilomètres.
Il s’arrêtait, recommençait, s’arrêtait, recommençait.
Ça c’est des préliminaires.
(Rires)
OK. J’ai presque -- j’étais à ça de changer d’espèce à ce moment-là.
Évidemment, la vie peut nous apprendre des choses
dans le domaine du divertissement, OK. La vie a beaucoup à nous apprendre.
Mais ce dont j’aimerais parler aujourd’hui
c'est ce que la vie pourrait nous apprendre en technologie et en design.
Ce qui s’est passé depuis que le livre est sorti --
le livre parlait principalement de recherche en bio-mimétisme.
Depuis, des architectes, des designers, des ingénieurs --
des gens qui font notre monde -- ont commencé à nous appeler et à dire,
nous voulons qu'un biologiste s'asseye à la table à dessin
pour nous aider, en temps réel, à trouver l'inspiration.
Ou -- et c’est ce qui m'amuse -- nous voulons que vous nous emmeniez
dans la nature. Nous arriverons avec un défi de design
et nous trouvons les as de l’adaptation dans la nature, qui pourraient nous inspirer.
Voici une photo d’un voyage aux Galápagos que nous avons fait
avec quelques ingénieurs en traitement des eaux usées; ils purifient l’eau usée.
Et certains d’entre eux étaient très réticents, en fait, à être là.
Ils nous ont d'abord dit, vous savez, nous faisons déjà du bio-mimétisme.
Nous utilisons des bactéries pour nettoyer notre eau. Alors nous avons dit,
bon, il ne s’agit pas vraiment -- ce n’est pas vraiment être inspiré par la nature.
C’est de la bio-production, vous voyez; C’est de la technologie bio-assistée:
utiliser un organisme pour traiter votre eau usée
est une vieille, vieille technologie appelée "domestication".
Il s’agit d’apprendre quelque chose, une idée, d’un organisme et de l’appliquer.
Et ils ne comprenaient toujours pas.
Alors nous sommes partis faire une ballade sur la plage et j'ai dit,
bon, donnez-moi l’un de vos gros problèmes. Donnez-moi un problème de design,
un ralentisseur de durabilité, qui vous empêche d’être durable.
Ils ont dit l’entartrage, qui est l’accumulation de minéraux à l’intérieur des tuyaux.
Et ils ont dit, ce qui se passe, c’est que les minéraux --
exactement comme à la maison -- les minéraux s’accumulent.
Alors l’ouverture se ferme, et nous devons nettoyer les tuyaux avec des toxines,
ou les curer.
Et donc si nous avions un moyen de stopper cet entartrage --
et alors, j'ai ramassé quelques coquillages sur la plage. Et je leur ai demandé,
qu'est-ce ce qui s'accumule? Qu’y a-t-il dans vos tuyaux?
Ils ont répondu, du carbonate de calcium.
Et j'ai dit, ça c'en est; c'est du carbonate de calcium.
Et ils ne le savaient pas.
Ils ne savaient pas qu’une coquille de coquillage,
part d'une matrice de protéines, puis les ions de l’eau de mer
cristallisent sur place, OK, pour créer une coquille.
Un processus du même type, sans les protéines,
se passe à l’intérieur de leurs tuyaux. Il ne le savaient pas.
Ce n’est pas par manque d’information; c’est un manque d’intégration.
Vous savez, c’est un silo, des gens dans des silos. Ils ne savaient pas
que la même chose se produisait. Alors, l’un d’entre eux y a réfléchi
et a dit, OK, bon, si c’est juste de la cristallisation
qui se produit automatiquement à partir d’eau de mer -- de l'auto-assemblage --
pourquoi les coquilles ne sont-elles pas infinies? Qu’est-ce qui arrête leur formation?
Pourquoi ne croissent-elles pas encore et toujours?
J'ai répondu, bon, de la même façon qu’elles relâchent des pro --
qu’elles sécrètent une protéine, ce qui commence la cristallisation --
et ils ont tous commencé à boire mes paroles --
elles relâchent une protéine qui stoppe la cristallisation.
Ça adhère littéralement à la face croissante du cristal.
Et, en fait, il y a un produit appelé TPA
qui imite cette protéine -- cette protéine stoppante --
et c’est une façon écologique d’arrêter l’entartrage dans les tuyaux.
Ça a tout changé. Ensuite,
on ne pouvait plus ramener les ingénieurs au bateau.
Le premier jour, ils ont fait une excursion,
et c’était, click, click, click, click. Cinq minutes après, ils étaient dans le bateau.
On a fini. Vous savez, j’ai vu cette île.
Après ça,
ils marchaient à quatre pattes partout. Ils n’allaient pas --
ils nageaient avec leur tuba aussi longtemps qu’on les laissait faire.
Ce qui s'est passé, c’est qu’ils ont réalisé qu’il y avait des organismes
dans la nature qui avaient déjà résolu les problèmes
qu'ils ont essayé de résoudre durant toute leur carrière.
Apprendre sur le monde naturel est une chose,
apprendre du monde naturel – la différence est là.
Voilà le changement profond.
Ce qu’ils ont réalisé, c’est que les réponses à leurs questions sont partout;
ils devaient juste changer les lunettes avec lesquelles ils voyaient le monde.
3,8 milliards d’années d'essais sur le terrain.
10 à 30 -- Craig Venter vous le dira probablement;
Je pense qu’il y a beaucoup plus de 30 millions -- de solutions bien adaptées.
L'important selon moi, c’est que ces solutions sont trouvées en contexte.
Et le contexte, c'est la Terre --
le même contexte dans lequel nous essayons de résoudre nos problèmes.
Il s’agit de prendre modèle sur le génie de la vie.
Pas de le mimer servilement --
bien qu’Albert essaie d’avoir la même coupe --
ce n’est pas une imitation servile. C’est prendre les principes de design,
le génie de la nature, et en apprendre quelque chose.
Maintenant, dans un groupe avec autant d’informaticiens, je dois mentionner que --
il y a un domaine dont je ne vais pas parler, parce que votre domaine
en est un qui a énormément appris des choses vivantes,
du côté du logiciel. Ainsi, il y a des ordinateurs qui se protègent eux-mêmes,
comme un système immunitaire, et nous apprenons de la régulation des gènes
et du développement biologique. Et nous apprenons des réseaux de neurones,
des algorithmes génétiques, du calcul évolutionnaire.
Voilà pour le côté logiciel. Mais ce qui m’intéresse
c’est que nous n’avons pas autant regardé ça. Je veux dire, ces machines
ne sont vraiment pas très high-tech à mon avis
dans la mesure où il y a des dizaines de substances cancérigènes
dans l’eau de la Silicon Valley.
Ainsi le matériel
n’est pas du tout au niveau de ce que la vie appellerait un succès.
Que peut-on apprendre pour fabriquer des ordinateurs, et le reste?
L’avion qui vous a amené, les voitures, les sièges où vous êtes assis.
Comment repenser le monde que nous faisons, que les humains font?
Et surtout, quelles questions poser dans les 10 années à venir?
Et il y a beaucoup de chouettes technologies dont la vie dispose.
Quel est le programme?
Trois questions, selon moi, sont cruciales.
Comment la vie fait-elle les choses?
Voilà l’opposé; ça c’est comment nous faisons les choses.
Ça s’appelle chauffer, battre et traiter --
c'est comme ça que les spécialistes des matériaux l’appellent.
Et ça consiste à tailler les choses dans la masse, avec 96 pour cent de déchets
et seulement 4 pour cent de produit. Vous chauffez, vous battez sous haute pression,
vous utilisez des produits chimiques. OK. Chauffer, battre et traiter.
La vie ne peut pas se le permettre. Comment fait-elle les choses?
Comment la vie utilise-t-elle au mieux les choses?
C’est du pollen de géranium.
Et sa forme est ce qui lui donne la capacité
de planer si facilement, OK. Regardez cette forme.
La vie ajoute de l’information à la matière.
En d'autres termes : de la structure.
Elle lui donne de l’information. En ajoutant de l’information à la matière,
elle lui donne un rôle différent de celui qu'elle a sans cette structure.
Et troisièmement, comment fait la vie pour transformer les choses en système?
Parce que la vie ne traite pas vraiment des choses;
rien n’existe dans la nature séparé
de son système.
Un programme très rapide.
A mesure que je lis de plus en plus, et que je suis ce qui se passe,
il y a des choses surprenantes qui se présentent en sciences biologiques.
Et en même temps, j’écoute de nombreuses entreprises
et je découvre quels sont leurs défis suprêmes.
Les deux groupes ne se parlent pas.
Du tout.
Qu'est-ce qui dans le monde de la biologie pourrait être utile, là,
pour sortir de cette sorte de point mort de l'évolution où nous sommes?
Je vais tenter d'examiner 12 points, très rapidement.
OK, un que je trouve excitant c’est l’auto-assemblage.
Pour le moment, vous en avez entendu parler en termes de nanotechnologies.
Revenons à cette coquille: la coquille est un matériel auto-assemblant.
En bas à gauche, il y a une image de nacre
se formant à partir d’eau de mer. C’est une structure en couche qui est d’abord minérale
puis polymère, et ça la rend très, très dure.
C’est deux fois plus dur que nos céramiques high-tech.
Mais le plus intéressant: contrairement à nos céramiques qui sont cuites,
cela se produit dans l’eau de mer. Dans et à côté du corps de l’organisme.
OK, les gens commencent --
voici les laboratoires Sandia; un certain Jeff Brinker
a trouvé un moyen de programmer un processus d’auto-assemblage.
Imaginez être capable de fabriquer des céramiques à température ambiante
simplement en trempant quelque chose dans un liquide,
en l’en ressortant, et que l’évaporation
regroupe les molécules du liquide,
de manière qu'elles s'assemblent
de la même manière que cette cristallisation a lieu.
Imaginez produire tous nos matériaux durs ainsi.
Imaginez pulvériser les précurseurs d’une cellule solaire,
sur un toit, et qu'elle s’auto-assemble en une structure feuilletée qui collecte la lumière.
Ça c’est quelque chose d’intéressant pour le monde de l’informatique:
bio-silicium. Ceci est une diatomée, qui est faite de silicates.
Le silicium que nous produisons actuellement --
ça fait partie du problème des cancérigènes dans la fabrication de nos puces --
ceci est un processus de bio-minéralisation qui est actuellement imité.
C’est à l’Université de Californie à Santa Barbara. Regardez ces diatomées;
cela fait partie des travaux de Ernst Haeckel.
Imaginez pouvoir -- et c’est encore un processus qui part d'une matrice,
et qui solidifie à partir de liquide -- imaginez pouvoir faire apparaître
ce genre de structure à température ambiante.
Imaginez pouvoir faire des lentilles parfaites.
À gauche, c’est une ophiure; elle est recouverte de lentilles
dont les gens de Lucent Technologies ont découvert
qu'elles n'avaient aucune distorsion.
C’est l’une des lentilles avec le moins de distorsion que nous connaissions.
Et il y en a beaucoup, partout sur son corps.
L'intéressant est là encore qu’elle s’auto-assemble.
Une femme du nom de Joanna Aizenberg, à Lucent,
apprend actuellement à le faire à basse température pour créer
ce genre de lentilles. Elle étudie aussi les fibres optiques.
Voici une éponge de mer qui a une fibre optique.
Tout à sa base, il y a des fibres optiques
qui marchent mieux que les nôtres, en fait, pour déplacer de la lumière.
mais vous pouvez les nouer; elles sont incroyablement flexibles.
Encore une autre grande idée: le CO2 comme source de nourriture.
Un certain Geoff Coates, à Cornell, s’est dit,
les plantes ne voient pas le CO2 comme le plus grand poison de notre temps.
C'est nous qui le voyons ainsi. Les plantes font de longues chaînes
d’amidons et de glucose -n’est-ce pas- à partir de CO2. Il a trouvé un moyen --
il a trouvé un catalyseur, et il a trouvé un moyen de prendre le CO2
et de le transformer en polycarbonates. Des plastiques biodégradables
à partir de CO2 – tout comme les plantes.
Les transformations solaires : le plus excitant.
Il y a des gens qui imitent le dispositif de récolte d’énergie
des bactéries violettes, les gens de l’ASU. Encore plus intéressant,
récemment, ces deux dernières semaines, des gens ont vu
qu’il y a une enzyme appelée hydrogénase, capable de créer
de l’hydrogène à partir de protons et d’électrons, et capable d’oxyder l’hydrogène --
en gros ce qui se passe à l’anode d’une pile à combustible
et dans une pile à combustible réversible.
Dans nos piles à combustible, nous le faisons avec du platine.
La vie le fait avec un fer très très commun.
Et une équipe vient juste de parvenir à imiter
cette hydrogénase qui jongle avec l’hydrogène.
C’est très enthousiasmant pour les piles à combustible --
être capable de le faire sans platine.
Le pouvoir des formes: voilà une baleine. Nous avons remarqué que ses ailerons
présentent des tubercules à leur surface. Et ces petites bosses
augmentent vraiment l’efficacité, par exemple,
du bord d'attaque d'une aile d'avion -- d’environ 32 pour cent.
Ce qui est une économie de carburant fossile impressionnante,
juste en mettant ça sur le bord d’une aile.
La couleur sans pigments: ce paon crée de la couleur par la forme.
La lumière traverse et est réfléchie par les couches;
ça s’appelle de l’interférence par une couche mince. Imaginez pouvoir
auto-assembler des produits dont les quelques dernières couches
jouent avec la lumière pour créer de la couleur.
Imaginez pouvoir créer une forme à l’extérieur d’une surface,
qui la rende autonettoyante juste avec de l’eau. C’est ce qu’une feuille fait.
Vous voyez cette image en gros plan ?
C’est une goutte d’eau et ce sont des particules de saleté.
Et voici une image en gros plan d’une feuille de lotus.
Une entreprise fabrique un produit appelé Lotusan, qui imite --
quand la peinture de la façade sèche, elle imite les bosses
d'une feuille autonettoyante, et l’eau de pluie nettoie le bâtiment.
L’eau va devenir notre défi suprême:
étancher la soif.
Voici deux organismes qui extraient de l’eau.
Celui de gauche est le scarabée de Namibie qui extrait de l’eau du brouillard.
Celui de droite est un cloporte -- il extrait l’eau de l’air.
Il ne boit pas d’eau.
Extraire l’eau du brouillard de Monterey et de l’air moite d’Atlanta,
avant qu’elle ne rentre dans un bâtiment, sont des technologies cruciales.
Les technologies de séparation vont être extrêmement importantes.
Supposons que nous disions plus d’extraction minière?
Supposons que nous extrayions les métaux des flux de déchets --
de petites quantités de métal de l’eau? C’est ce que les microbes font,
ils fixent les métaux de l’eau.
Il y a une entreprise ici à San Francisco nommée MR3
qui incorpore aux filtres des imitations des molécules de ces microbes
pour extraire les métaux des flux de déchets.
La chimie verte est la chimie dans l'eau.
Nous faisons de la chimie dans des solvants organiques.
C’est une image des filières d’une araignée, OK,
et de la soie que l’araignée produit. N’est-ce pas magnifique?
La chimie verte remplace notre chimie industrielle par le livre de recettes de la nature.
Ce n’est pas facile, car la vie n’utilise
qu’une partie des éléments du tableau périodique.
Et nous les utilisons tous, même les toxiques.
Trouver d'élégantes recettes, utilisant le petit sous-ensemble
du tableau périodique, et créant des matériaux miracles comme cette cellule,
c'est la tâche de la chimie verte.
La décomposition programmée : un emballage qui soit bon
jusqu'à ce que vous ne vouliez plus qu’il le soit, et le dissoudre sur commande.
Voici une moule telle qu'on en trouve ici.
Les fils qui la tiennent au rocher ont une durée limitée -- au bout de deux ans,
ils commencent à se dissoudre.
Guérir : voilà un point intéressant.
Cette petite bête-là est un tardigrade.
Il y a un problème mondial de vaccins
qui n’arrivent pas jusqu’aux patients. La raison en est
que la réfrigération est rompue d’une façon ou d’une autre;
ce qu’on appelle la "chaîne du froid" est rompue.
Un certain Bruce Rosner a regardé le tardigrade --
qui se dessèche complètement, et pourtant reste vivant pendant des mois,
des mois et des mois, et est capable de se régénérer.
Et il a trouvé un moyen de dessécher les vaccins --
de les enfermer dans la même sorte de capsules de sucre
que le tardigrade a dans ces cellules --
ce qui signifie que les vaccins n’ont plus besoin d’être réfrigérés.
Ils peuvent être mis dans la boîte à gant, OK.
Apprendre des organismes. C’est une session à propos de l’eau --
apprendre sur les organismes qui n’ont pas besoin d’eau,
pour pouvoir créer un vaccin qui dure, dure et dure sans réfrigération.
Je ne vais pas aller jusqu’à 12.
Mais ce que je vais faire, c’est vous dire que la chose la plus importante,
en dehors de toutes ces adaptations, est le fait que ces organismes
ont trouvé un moyen de faire les choses incroyables qu’ils font
tout en prenant soin de l’endroit
qui va prendre soin de leur descendance.
Quand ils sont engagés dans les préliminaires,
ils pensent à quelque chose de très, très important:
que leur matériel génétique
existe pour encore 10 000 générations.
Et ça signifie trouver une façon de faire ce qu’ils font
sans détruire l’endroit qui va prendre soin de leur descendance.
C’est le plus grand défi en matière de design.
Par chance, il y a des millions et des millions de génies
prêts à nous faire don de leurs meilleures idées.
Bonne chance durant votre conversation avec eux.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson: en parlant de préliminaires, je -- nous avons besoin d’aller jusqu’à 12, mais vraiment vite.
Janine Benyus: Oh, vraiment?
CA : Oui. Juste avec, vous savez, avec la version 10 secondes
de 10, 11 et 12. Parce que nous -- vos transparents sont si beaux,
et les idées sont si fortes, je ne peux pas vous laisser repartir
sans voir 10, 11 et 12.
JB : OK, mettez ça -- OK, je vais juste tenir ce truc. OK, génial.
OK, donc c’est la partie guérison.
Sentir et réagir: le feedback est une chose essentielle.
Voilà un locuste. Il peut y en avoir 80 millions par kilomètre carré,
et pourtant ils n’entrent jamais en collision entre eux.
Et malgré tout nous avons 3,6 millions de collisions de voitures par an.
(Rires)
Entendu. Il y a une personne à Newcastle
qui a compris que c’est un très gros neurone.
Et elle cherche comment faire
un circuit électronique d’évitement de collision
basé sur ce très gros neurone du locuste.
Celui là est un point très important, le numéro 11.
Et c’est cultiver la fertilité.
Cela signifie, vous voyez, la culture de la fertilité.
Nous devrions cultiver la fertilité. Ah oui -- et nous obtenons de la nourriture, aussi.
Parce que nous devons augmenter la capacité de cette planète
à créer de plus en plus d’opportunités pour la vie.
Et vraiment, c’est ce que les autres organismes font aussi.
De façon générale, c’est ce que les écosystèmes entiers font:
ils créent de plus en plus d’opportunités pour la vie.
Notre agriculture a fait l’inverse.
Une agriculture basée sur la formation par la prairie de la terre,
l’élevage basé sur la manière dont un troupeau naturel d’ongulés
augmente effectivement la santé de la prairie.
Et même le traitement des eaux usées basé sur la façon dont un marais
non seulement nettoie l’eau,
mais crée aussi une productivité incroyablement foisonnante.
C’est la mission simple du design. Je veux dire, ça a l’air simple
parce que le système, durant 3,8 milliards d’année, l’a élaboré.
Autrement dit, ces organismes qui n’ont pas été capables de trouver
comment améliorer ou adoucir leurs milieux,
ne sont plus ici pour nous en parler.
C’est le douzième point.
La vie -- et c’est l'astuce ; le tour de magie --
la vie crée des conditions favorables à la vie.
Elle produit la terre, elle nettoie l’air, elle nettoie l’eau,
elle prépare le cocktail de gaz dont vous et moi avons besoin pour vivre.
Et elle fait ça en plein milieu de super préliminaires
et tout en satisfaisant leurs besoins. Ce n’est donc pas mutuellement exclusif.
Nous devons trouver un moyen de satisfaire nos besoins,
tout en faisant de cet endroit un Eden.
CA : Janine, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)